[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight so much going on in your
government it's very hard to keep track
even if you're paid to do it as we are
here's one interesting thing that nobody
noticed on saturday some unnamed actor
some subterranean vermill in the house
of representatives inserted what turned
out to be a remarkable provision into
the so-called budget reconciliation bill
almost nobody outside the congress
noticed it was there and that's really
not surprising the bill is one of the
biggest in all of human history it's
nearly 2500 pages long
it spends 3.5 trillion dollars where
does that money come from well it was
just newly printed by the federal
reserve for the occasion
the provision in question was hidden on
page 168
of that bill and here's what it says
going forward the federal government
will bankrupt any company that refuses
to comply with joe biden's vaccine
mandate
so do you have an unvaccinated worker in
your office
the fine for that will be seven hundred
thousand dollars payable to the us
treasury for each and every one of those
workers
even by the standards of washington that
is a lot of money here's a comparison in
june the federal government penalized a
chemical company in west virginia after
its plant exploded killing an employee
and sending two others to the hospital
the fine in that case twelve thousand
two hundred eighty eight dollars
so there you have it written out in
black and white the moral priorities of
the democratic party killing people in
chemical plants is bad
it's about twelve thousand dollars bad
but failing to get a joe biden mandated
coveted vaccine even if you've already
recovered from covet and have natural
immunity that is more powerful than any
shot
that's much much worse how much worse
it is 58 times worse than killing people
in a chemical plant explosion democrats
did the math on that and they wrote it
down
this whole approach if you take three
steps back to covet is a little weird
when you think about it if you really
wanted to protect the public the
american people from this virus the
first thing you would do is encourage
them to be healthy meaning get off your
phone get outside spend some time in
nature maybe lose some weight that's
meaningful that all works we know it for
a fact it's science
and then people with higher risk factors
like
older people people with pre-existing
medical problems would probably want to
get the vaccine definitely worth it for
them they should
everyone else could look at the numbers
and assess they could choose for
themselves as they do with every other
medical decision
the federal government is not requiring
you to get surgery for prostate cancer
if you get it no you get to decide
so that would be a reasonable response
to covet it might actually improve the
country rather than destroy it
but that's very far from what they're
actually doing and the reason is
politics from the beginning of the
outbreak politicians have turned what
they told us was a public health
response into something that very much
looks like a political campaign and in a
political campaign the other side is
your enemy
so all of a sudden the public has become
an opponent that politicians must subdue
and defeat
how do you feel about opponents you are
working to subdue and defeat
will you feel loathing and contempt and
that's how they do feel they're not
hiding it anymore
take a look at this video which we just
got it's from yesterday it shows a
democratic congresswoman from iowa
called cindy axne and she's explaining
her party's response to covid
she doesn't say anything that remarkable
it's how she says it
listen to how she talks about her
constituents she so clearly hates them
watch so now all the schools are back
wanting to put mass mandates in and all
the the anti-vaxxer crazies are out
there with their you know they're it's
it's a it's a hot mess i'll be honest
you know
christian right is you know the
everything under the guise while they
hold across and you know for god or
whatever and they and they use it like a
weapon and it's painful to watch because
they've they've weaponized religion
they've weaponized politics
yeah the christians are weaponizing it
notice all the abortion clinics they
closed oh no it was democratic
politicians who closed the churches
actually
speaking of weaponizing public health
but you just heard the congresswoman the
anti-vaxxer crazies the christians
holding a cross for god or whatever
it's hard to remember those are actually
human beings she's talking about some of
the weakest human beings in our country
but she would never know they're real
people because she clearly loathes them
she hates them
you hear this tone a lot from
politicians all of a sudden a lot
it's not sympathy it's certainly not
empathy it's not even a sincere attempt
to make people better or healthier
it's hate
here's the mayor of new york threatening
to hurt anyone who doesn't get the shot
whether they need it or not listen
most people the vast majority of people
even those who say i didn't want to get
vaccinated
make a different decision when it
becomes very very practical so now
someone is really looking at the
possibility they won't have a paycheck
for a prolonged period of time they may
even lose their job ultimately
a lot of people don't look at that and
say hold up okay i'll get vaccinated
oh we'll take your paycheck away
just punch you in the face or starve you
to death when we beat up your kids
turns out if you hurt people enough they
will do exactly what you say
so that actually works bill de blasio is
clearly a [ __ ] but even he understands
that and it does work united airlines
just announced it is firing nearly 600
people
why are they doing that well they don't
want to pay tens of millions of dollars
in fines
so now 600 people who last week worked
united airlines are unemployed oh by the
way they have no health insurance that's
how we're making america healthier got
it
and it's not just happening in the
airlines in hospitals across the
countries mass firings are now underway
where's the congress on this good
question meanwhile one hospital system
in north carolina just canned
175 people
remember this is a public health crisis
we're living through right so maybe we
shouldn't empty the hospitals of their
seasoned employees it was already
nationwide a severe shortage of nurses
hospitals are closing wings because
there's no one to staff them and now
there are fewer people
none of the people who've been fired
will be able to collect unemployment by
the way they're done they're destroyed
they're not just punished they're
crushed
and these aren't the ceos of big
companies these aren't people who live
in affluent neighborhoods these are
hourly workers these are people the
democratic party used to care about
these are people with no power
whatsoever who worked around sick people
for the duration of a deadly pandemic
and rather than thank them we're firing
them with no unemployment benefits and
no health insurance
and a lot of them state of new york for
example the deadline for health care
workers to get vaccine is already passed
according to the most recent figures 16
percent of the state's hospital workers
that is 83 000 people remain
unvaccinated eight percent of those
workers have not gotten a single dose of
the vaccine that means they're going to
be fired
so the question is once again who's
going to staff the hospitals in the
middle of this public health crisis well
that's an easy answer according to the
new governor of new york the one no one
voted for the state of new york is going
to use the military to do it and then
hire temp workers from the philippines
it's lunacy
and by the way once again why exactly
are all these health care workers
thousands of them nationwide refusing to
get the covid vaccine
that is an entirely fair question and no
one is asking it
it might be worth finding out you can't
say these are people who don't
understand the science in fact they
might know more about covet and
healthcare than your average democratic
governor considering that's what they do
for a living they treat people with
covid
every single day
so it's not like they're uninformed what
is this exactly
it's not a few people it's thousands of
people why no one cares
punish them the weakest
now crushed
meanwhile as we're firing nurses and
doctors we're admitting thousands of
illegal immigrants into this country
right now many of them infected with
diseases including covid
you're not supposed to say that because
it's some sort of
slur
but it's factually true
in fact
not only is it true the secretary of
homeland security just admitted it he
explained that 20
of the people coming across the border
have an unidentified illness of some
kind here he is
we are confronted with a
a
a population of people
that um
[Music]
as a general matter
um have a
a a rate
of illness of approximately 20 percent
oh
okay
so we're firing healthcare workers
because they won't get the vaccine and
then letting in thousands of people
whose identities we can't verify who are
sick with diseases we can't always
identify including covid none of them
are required to get the vaccine in
contrast to the nurses we just fired
that leaves our hospitals short staffed
many more sick people coming in who will
need treatment at public expense
who's doing this
and why
what is the point
they're telling us that health care
workers need to be fired immediately
because they're a threat to the country
this is all happening very very quickly
and it's happening without any medical
basis whatsoever remember it was just
last year that joe biden was telling us
that health care workers are heroes and
he was right
to all the doctors and nurses working in
the icu units help you all know you're
truly some of the greatest heroes this
nation has seen
take tracy in massachusetts she's a
nurse
who's been treating veterans with coven
19.
every day she's had to put on a hazmat
suit and go to work for 12 hours days on
end it wasn't for folks like tracy our
own families wouldn't have a chance to
be reunited we want to find a hero in
america they're all around us and
tracy's one of them
don't often endorse joe biden videos but
that's 100 right anyone who's ever been
sick and ever spent any time in the
hospital knows that one good nurse makes
all the difference they really are some
of the best people in the country
so why are we firing thousands of them
why is joe biden doing this as a
scientific matter it doesn't make any
sense unvaccinated healthcare workers do
not pose a threat to their vaccinated
patients or co-workers period
if you're vac stand you will likely be
fine that's what the data show that's
what they tell us day after day
vaccinated people have a greater chance
of dying from a lightning strike than
they do of dying from covet they're more
likely to die of a bee sting or a dog
attack or from choking to death in their
food those the numbers where you hear
them very often
so why are unvaccinated people a threat
to them not one person has answered that
question no one's even asking it
why are we firing them why are we
blaming them why are we in their face
attacking them
demonizing them but no one's pushing
back so it's accelerating this is coming
to the border patrol as well it's coming
the entire federal government mass
firings are likely to occur in the
border patrol's ranks when the federal
government's vaccine mandate is enforced
later this year
it's crazy
but if there's one sad lesson maybe the
status lesson of this pandemic it's that
authoritarianism is very popular with
certain parts of the population and if
you need evidence of that take a look at
the scene last night the new jersey new
jersey gubernatorial debate
listen to the crowd's reaction as phil
murphy equates not getting the covid
shot to drunk driving
saying that it's your call and
governments can't mandate a vaccine
or or no masking is akin to supporting
drunk driving it impacts both the person
who's driving drunk but all the rest of
us
that's not the way we beat this
how is it like drunk driving how do
unvaccinated people hurt anybody hey
phil murphy got a second
we've got some time why don't you
explain that to us
it was just a year ago or so that a
politician who got on stage and said
that would be laughed off the stage and
a politician who endorsed firing
thousands of health care workers during
a pandemic
calling them criminals dehumanizing them
would be reviled now it gets applause
not because the science has changed the
science is the same
it's because our leaders realized how to
leverage fear to crush their political
opponents and if that means finding
people seven hundred thousand dollars
for employing someone
throwing the weakest people in our
society out on the street with no
unemployment insurance
and no health insurance
they'll do it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else